und jetzt das heute journal
mit kaiser richter und christian sievers
guten abend hinein langweilig wird es
nicht das ist aber auch schon das
einzige was planbar ist wenn das
britische parlament über den brics it
entscheidet alles andere ist achterbahn
heute sollte der große tag werden die
entscheidende abstimmung über den neuen
deal mit der eu der großbritanniens
austritt in knapp zwei wochen besiegeln
sollte stattdessen gab es erst eine
faustdicke überraschung und dann dieses
gefühl in einer endlos wiederkehrenden
zeitschleife gefangen zu sein und
täglich grüßt das murmeltier
die mehrfach mit ihrem brett citydeal im
parlament gescheiterte theresa may
brachte es auf den punkt und am ende
dieses aufreibenden tages in westminster
sind wir tatsächlich in der sache keinen
schritt weiter das parlament verschiebt
seine entscheidung zwingt den premier
damit eine verlängerung der praxis frist
zu beantragen obwohl der immer gesagt
hatte nur über meine leiche aus london
diana zimmermann
es war vielleicht nicht der höhepunkt
des brh exit dramas aber es war der
höhepunkt des misstrauens der heute in
london zu erleben war
der exit freundlicher abgeordnete
trauten sich nicht allein auf die straße
weil ganz london von exit gegner war die
für ein zweites referendum
demonstrierten
ich bin so enttäuscht von meinem land
ich habe das gefühl mir wurde die
zukunft entrissen
ich war zu jung zu wählen ich möchte
nichts lieber als in der eu bleiben
wir brauchen noch ein referendum das
letzte basierte auf unwissenheit ihr
wurden belogen lügen und gebrochene
versprechen haben dazu geführt dass
keiner dem anderen mehr über den weg
traut zwischen regierung und opposition
mag das noch normal sein
der premier hat im sommer gesagt unter
keinen umständen werde ich ist der eu
oder irgendwem gestatten eine trennlinie
in der irischen see zu ziehen
man kann kein wort von dem glauben was
er sagt die nordirischen unionisten die
johnsons regierung eigentlich stützen
sehen das inzwischen genauso heute
stimmten sie gegen ihn weil es mit
seinem die leben doch eine zollgrenze in
der irischen see geben wird als
entscheidend erwies sich an diesem tag
wie sehr die abgeordneten sich unter
einander misstrauen oliver letwin geht
es für möglich dass manche seiner
ehemaligen konservativen parteikollegen
zwar heute für den deal stimmen dann
aber die weitere gesetzgebung blockieren
könnten
damit hätte wieder der chaos dragset
gedroht advance änderungsantrag hatte
erfolg johnson muss noch vor mitternacht
eine verlängerung in brüssel beantragen
das beste für das königreich und ganz
europa wäre wenn wir am 31 oktober mit
diesem neuen die
austreten würden ich werde übrigens
keine verlängerung mit der eu aushandeln
und das gesetz zwingt mich dazu auch
nicht reiner bluff verhandlungen sind
tatsächlich gar nicht nötig er muss nur
einen brief abschicken
das machen und er wird natürlich
probieren den sein die wieder vor dem
parlament zu bringen bevor den 31
oktober weil er hat versprochen und das
ist die höchste priorität für ihn dass
wir vor den 31 oktober die eu verlassen
die gute nachricht für den premier
berichte auch dieses versprechen wird er
damit nur wenige wirklich enttäuschend
vor zwei wochen sagten drei viertel der
briten dass sie an einen austritt im
oktober sowieso nicht mehr glauben so
und jetzt heißt es bei der eu boris
johnson wird noch heute abend diesen
brief schicken bis mitternacht hat er
noch zeit diesen brief in dem er um
verlängerung bitten
das heißt aber nicht dass er auf gibt es
trotzdem noch bis 31 10 zu schaffen
mit seinem deal andreas staben london
wie will er das schaffen
ja diesen brief muss r schreiben da kann
man gar nicht drum rum das gesetz was
die nazi zwingt ist einfach wasserdicht
aber was er nicht muss und das hatte
auch heute mehrmals betont er muss nicht
mit brüssel mit der eu verhandeln
zumindest nicht sofort heißt also
erstmal abwarten vielleicht kriegt er
diesen deal eben doch noch durchs
parlament und in brüssel da werden sie
wohl warten denn die wollen ja genau so
dass dieser deal durchgeht dass dieser
alptraum endlich endet so die
kalkulation in london und zwölf tage bis
zum 31 oktober sind eben in der
britischen politik und das weiß man ja
nun eine verdammt lange zeit
auf jeden fall das wissen wir wirklich
gucken wir dann nach brüssel stefan
leifert wie wie sieht's aus warten
wartet die eu einfach ab was da jetzt
kommt reibt sich die augen und staunt
einfach nur noch oder hat sie auch einen
konkreten plan eine strategie ja
gestaunt hat man heute schon aber auch
ziemlich viel telefoniert hier innerhalb
brüssels und zwischen brüssel und den
hauptstädten und inzwischen ist die
marschroute doch etwas klarer geworden
morgen früh um halb zehn treffen sich
wenn der
liefern heute abend hier ein geht die
eu-botschafter um in sachen brett zu
beraten aber wie es aussieht werden sie
noch keine antwort geben auf die frage
verlängerung ja oder nein solange in
london noch eine realistische chance
besteht dass der deal von boris johnson
eine mehrheit bekommt so lange hat man
hier noch zeit abzuwarten wenn er eine
mehrheit bekommt dann glaubt man in
brüssel ist ein geordneter ausstieg am
31 oktober noch möglich wenn nicht wenn
der deal scheitert dann stellt sich die
frage der verlängerung und es spricht
viel dafür dass es diese verlängerung am
ende auch geben wird so sehr bei manchen
auch der geduldsfaden langsam reißt ist
die devise aber nach wie vor einen
ungeordneten rexit unter allen umständen
zu vermeiden also brüssel hat einen plan
guckt aber erstmal bis mitte nächster
woche nach london und wir gucken auch
noch mal ganz kurz nach london andreas
wenn wir uns diesen tag noch mal kurz
revue passieren lassen diesen irren tage
sind weiteren tag in london geht nach
dem tag irgendjemand als sieger vom
platz
ich glaube in so einem tag geht keiner
als sieger vom platz
wenn man wirklich die stimmung unter den
leuten in der bevölkerung mal so gefühlt
hat den letzten wochen dann ist dieses
momentum dass das mal endlich aufhören
muss wirklich unglaublich stark und das
tut es ja wieder nicht und vielleicht
gibt es doch zwei sieger zum einen eben
die nordirischen unionisten diese die op
die ja eigentlich die die koalition die
regierung von boris johnson unterstützt
und die hat er ja wirklich sozusagen
verraten und verkaufen und die haben
sich heute gerecht denn das wenn die
zehn stimmen gewesen die gereicht hätten
und zum zweiten die die heute wirklich
viel umsatz und geld gemacht haben das
dürfte die bar das pub im parlament sein
denn unmittelbarsten unmittelbar nach
der abstimmung gab es schon lange
schlangen dort und ich glaube die sind
bis spät in die nacht da wahrscheinlich
noch weiter aktiv denn ansonsten ist das
auch wirklich im moment kaum zu ertragen
tschüss nach london und nach brüssel hat
sich dank liebe kollegen wiedervorlage
nächste woche und damit nach deutschland
wenn der fahrer ordentlich aufs tempo
drückt und die im anhänger ausscheren
dann führt das auf der autobahn zum
unfall beim csu parteitag zu einer
kompromisslösung in letzter minute um
die erste schwere niederlage von markus
söder als parteichef wenigstens nicht
ganz so schwer aussehen zu lassen
söder gerade frisch im amt bestätigt
will
eine partei umkrempeln fit machen für
die zukunft
aber die partei will nicht zumindest
nicht so wie ihr chef
und das zeigt sich dann heute als es
hektisch wird auf dem parteitag beim
thema frauenquote patricia schäfer und
alexander pohl hier entgleitet gerade
etwas nicht nur gesichtszüge sondern ein
zentraler punkt der parteireform für die
sich der frisch im amt bestätigte
csu-chef heute feiern lassen wollte
stattdessen wurde markus söder kalt
erwischt eine wortmeldung nach der
anderen gegen die ausweitung der
frauenquote in der csu
negativ vom bösen waren gar keine frau
hochkommen lassen will
in den vorständen das stimmt einfach
nicht in absoluter blödsinn jede frau
die was kann der tat in dieser bei der
fünften staffel
ich mag auch nicht ständig mit dem
rechenschieber als kreisvorsitzender
dann letztendlich ausrechnen müssen wie
wir die quoten erfüllen die wir uns auch
verleger die quote das aushängeschild
für diesen parteitag droht zu scheitern
kriegsrat der parteispitze alles was
rang und namen hat tritt jetzt vorsah
mikrofon wir haben heute junge frauen im
bezirksvorstand die ohne die vorgabe
nicht gewählt worden wären wir führen
heute keine gute ein sondern wir geben
sie auf die kreisebene und ich muss
sagen dort wo es funktioniert dann ist
es doch selbstverständlich
und dort wo man vielleicht noch ein
bisschen signale setzen muss das darf
doch nicht das problem für uns sein
tatsächlich hat die csu bereits seit
langem eine frauenquote 40 prozent im
parteivorstand und den bezirken jetzt
sollte sie zusätzlich für kreisvorstände
gelten
nach zwei stunden hitziger debatte tritt
markus söder selbst in den ring und
mahnt die delegierten wenigstens einem
kompromiss zuzustimmen die quote nur
noch als soll nicht mehr als muss wird
mir den kompromiss der frauen union
nicht annehmen
das liebe freunde dann ist es doch ein
schlag ins gesicht so viele engagierte
frau ist kann doch nicht ernsthaft der
wunsch einen wir als csu von diesem
parteitag aussehen der kompromiss geht
durch wie auch das gesamte reformpaket
doch am ende bleibt der eindruck die csu
will näher am menschen sein ist aber
weit entfernt von teilen der eigenen
basis server bleibt noch moment beim
csu-parteitag karrenbauer verdient einen
blick schließlich war das verhältnis der
beiden schwesterparteien in den
vergangenen jahren nicht immer gut
entsprechend beschwor kramp karrenbauer
noch einmal die geschlossenheit der
union der streit um die
flüchtlingspolitik sei zerstörerisch
gewesen das dürfe nicht noch einmal
passieren
in barcelona sind wieder etliche
anhänger der unabhängigkeitsbewegung auf
den straßen den sechsten tag in folge zu
destillieren sie gegen haftstrafen die
das oberste spanische gericht gegen
separatistenführer verhängt hatte
vergangene nacht waren tausende
demonstranten auf polizisten losgegangen
die antworteten mit tränengas und
wasserwerfern
mehr als 180 menschen wurden verletzt
zuvor hatten gut eine halbe million
menschen friedlich demonstriert
es war die größte anti terror übung die
es je in deutschland gegeben hat zehn
tage nach der gewalt in halle haben
polizei und bundeswehr einen fiktiven
anschlag in konstanz geübt vom ersten
notruf bis zur versorgung von verletzten
und 2500 menschen nahmen an der übung
teil die ein ganzes jahr lang
vorbereitet worden war
dabei lag ein besonderer fokus auf der
kommunikation zwischen bundeswehr und
polizei unterdessen gab es in halle ein
großes und idar ii teetz konzert
mindestens 14.000 menschen erinnerten
auf dem marktplatz an die anschlagsopfer
[Musik]
auf der bühne standen unter anderem
lloris max wiesinger und michael schulte
damit wollten sie ein zeichen gegen hass
und ausgrenzung setzen
das konzert ist auch ein dank an die
polizei und rettungskräfte die vor zehn
tagen im einsatz war der krieg im norden
von syrien hat längst deutschland
erreicht nicht mit waffengewalt
natürlich aber hoch emotionalen irgendwo
außerhalb ihrer angestammten gebiete
leben mehr kunden als bei uns geschätzt
rund eine million
während die waffenruhe des
us-präsidenten immer noch nicht wirklich
umfassend greift und völlig offen ist
was passiert wenn die frist dafür am
dienstag abläuft versuchen die kurden in
deutschland druck zu machen mit
demonstrationen heute in köln und in
anderen städten die ganze woche über
hatte es immer wieder
auseinandersetzungen gegeben zwischen
kurden und türken die in deutschland
leben jan hofer berichtet die türkische
militär offensive die toten die
vertriebenen weil das treibt sie auf die
straße 10.000 demonstranten in köln der
kriege nordsyrien er verändert auch das
verhältnis von kurden und türken in
deutschland
wir vermeiden jetzt harte diskussionen
damit wir keine wie sagt man
auseinandersetzungen hier führung dass
keine wir sind irgendwie freunde auch
gleichzeitig nur halb viele tippen sie
unterstützen leiter erdogan und sehen
uns hier nicht wirklich als menschen die
auch ihre rechte haben
die stimmung wird aufgeheizt alle
türkischen geschäfte entlang des
demonstrationszuges werden heute von der
polizei bewacht der alltag ist
grundsätzlich belastet auch manche
türken empfinden das so
also ich muss sagen uns beeinträchtigt
das in der hinweise dass wir jetzt ein
bisschen angst habe weil ich gesagt dass
wir jetzt angekurbelt werden eventuell
was hier sichtbar wird ist ein alter
konflikt der jetzt auch in deutschland
erneut eskaliert wenn menschen nach
deutschland kommen kommen mit ihnen
natürlich auch ihre politischen
einstellungen auch konfliktlagen man
importiert nicht quasi ein konflikt was
nicht da ist sondern ein komplett was da
ist kommt mit den menschen nach
deutschland
orte dieses konfliktes zum beispiel
lüdenscheid diese woche bei einer
kurdischen mahnwache wird ein deutsch
türke niedergestochen
in bottrop werden am mittwoch bei einer
auseinandersetzung zwischen kurden und
türken acht menschen verletzt
zu solcher gewalt kommt es heute in köln
nicht die polizei dritten massiv auf
[Musik]
wasserwerfer reiterstaffel
ob das letztlich dazu beigetragen hat
dass menschen gar nicht erst gekommen
sind dass kein bus aus wirklich sein in
köln ist heute friedlicher protest
möglich der konflikt selbst aber ist
noch lange nicht gelöst
und nochmal nachrichten in der berliner
s bahn station bellevue ist ein
sonderzug mit hunderten fußballfans in
brand geraten
mindestens drei menschen erlitten
rauchvergiftungen sämtliche waggons
wurden geräumt ebenso wie zwei s bahnen
die auf nachbar gleisen stehen der
bahnverkehr zwischen tiergarten und
friedrichstraße wurde gestoppt
an bord des zuges waren fans des sc
freiburgs die vom bundesligaspiel gegen
union berlin zurückfahren wollten
er galt als urgestein der spd als
vordenker und kein bequemer nun ist
erhard eppler gestorben im alter von 92
jahren
im laufe der jahrzehnte übernahm der
spd-politiker etliche ämter
so war er entwicklungshilfeminister
unter willy brandt engagierte sich auch
in der friedensbewegung und der
evangelischen kirche außerdem setzte er
sich für den umweltschutz ein
er selbst sagte einmal es habe wohl
keinen tag gegeben an dem sich die spd
nicht über ihn geärgert habe samstag ist
lotto tag hier sind die zahl 4 711 33 38
39 superzahl 9
die angaben sind ohne gewähr weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto zdf de
und im zdf text auf seite 55 61 im
nordwesten wohnen dann müssen sie jetzt
ganz stark sein oder sie sollten regen
denn davon bekommt die note westhälfte
morgen ziemlich viel ab bei 13 bis 19
grad sonst wird es bei 19 bis 26 grad
meist freundlich in südbayern sonnig an
den alpen für mich auch die neue woche
beginnt im norden und westen mit regen
ab dienstag wird das wetter dann aber
ruhiger mit 13 bis 23 grad ist es für
ende oktober sehr wird wie schön auf der
frankfurter buchmesse gibt es nichts zu
ermitteln und trotzdem tummeln sich dort
gerade lauter tatort kommissare die
promis aus dem fernsehkrimi sind auf
buchtour können schauspieler schreiben
manche von ihnen bekommen begeisterte
kritiken für ihre werke bei anderen
sollte die frage vielleicht besser
lauten müssen schauspieler überhaupt
schreiben können
denn bei einem prominenten gesicht auf
dem cover ist der platz auf der
bestsellerliste fast schon garantiert
und die buchmessen fans freut es volle
hallen lange schlangen an den
signiertisch heute ist der erste tag für
das publikum in frankfurt und linken
klinge nimmt uns mit
geduldig warten die leser um sich das
neue buch des großen schauspielers
signieren zu lassen
ulrich tukur schreibt schon seit einigen
jahren
dies ist sein erster roman der ursprung
der welt beginnt in der zukunft ein mann
entdeckt in einem alten fotoalbum
jemanden der ihm zum verwechseln ähnlich
sieht und begibt sich auf spurensuche in
die zeit des nationalsozialismus
düsteres mischt mit fantastischen das
hat ihn gereizt
in der literatur kann man halt räume
kann man geschichten kann man welten
kreieren die die partie eigenen sind als
man ist jetzt nicht mehr wie im theater
und film abhängig von von vorhandenem
material vor allem von einem guten
drehbuch und form von kamera und und
regisseure mannschaft das selber und das
ist natürlich sagen wir mal finde ich
dann schon die königsdisziplin
viele schauspieler schreiben inzwischen
ihre eigenen geschichten den verlagen
beschert das meist gute verkaufszahlen
literaturkritiker begeistern sich nicht
immer für die neuen romanciers doch am
ende sind bücher für die leser und die
sind angetan und voller erwartungen
wenn man die personen dann einfach kennt
und ansonsten hat man immer irgendeine
vorstellung von einem schriftsteller
stift schriftstellerin wenn man
irgendein buch liest aber so hat man
noch mal eine andere beziehung dazu
rennen schauspieler schreiben das kann
schon sehr interessant sollen ja warum
weil es einfach nur noch eine andere
perspektive ist von der bande aus dem
anderen künstlerischen bereich immer aus
dem schauspieler andrea sawatzki haben
bücher schon ihr leben lang fasziniert
sagt sie und sie hat sich mit ihrer
heiteren romanhelden gundula bundschuh
eine rolle direkt auf den leib
geschneidert dies ist band 4
die ersten teile hat das zdf verfilmt
ich glaube das war bei mir auch einen
grund mit dem schreiben anzufangen weil
mir das manchmal in den rollen die ich
gespielt habe nicht auf dem punkt genug
war also die figuren nicht genug
durchleuchtet hat so dass man immer noch
was dazu erfinden musste im spiel oder
so und ich wollte jetzt mal so eine
figur als ganzes für mich erschaffen
schauspieler sollten sich gut in ihre
charaktere hineindenken können in diesem
bücherherbst sind sie eine feste größe
so wir reden in dieser sendung die ganze
sendung über diesen brief den boris
johnson
der britische premierminister nach
brüssel schicken muss nach diesem tag
heute im parlament und in dem er um eine
verschiebung des black city bitten muss
der brief sollte bis mitternacht
eingetroffen seien jetzt können wir
melden er ist tatsächlich dahin brüssel
aber boris johnson der diesen brief ja
eigentlich kann ich schreiben wollte hat
ihn nicht unterschrieben das ist also
seine kleine note bei der ganzen
geschichte und damit lassen wir sie in
dieser samstagnacht morgen mehr 21.45
vielen dank fürs zuschauen
[Musik]